nie hätten sie gedacht dass es soweit
kommt daniel moder und seine frau laura
verlassen spanien ihre heimat
[Musik]
im moment gehen viele vor allem solcher
ohne job aber bei ihnen ist das anders
denn sie müssten nicht und gehen
trotzdem
spaniens elite wandert ab warum diese
frage soll uns durch diesen film
begleiten
[Musik]
farrell galizien familie morita ist
bereit für die schweiz daniel hat sich
auf ein schweizer stelleninserat
beworben und wurde mit handkuss genommen
und während er im wallis die probezeit
bestanden hat haben mutter und tochter
in spanien deutsch gebüffelt
laura und die kleine anti wollen sich
von ihrem deutschlehrer verabschieden
drei monate schon mal eine letzte
deutschstunde bist du sicher
klaus kalinowski unterrichtet schon
lange deutsch hier in führung
aber derzeit ist er besonders gefragt
wie die moria das verlassen fehler die
stadt am atlantik an tia ist vier jahre
alt sie spricht zwar kaum deutsch aber
sie versteht offensichtlich schon sehr
viel
[Musik]
ein tier kann sich nicht vorstellen was
auf sie zukommt bald wird sie in einen
schweizer kindergarten gehen
[Musik]
freunde kommen um matthäus zu sagen
die ganzen sorgen
[Musik]
daniel wirkt locker und entspannt
laura ist sehr zurückhaltend
es sind ihre letzten tage in der eigenen
wohnung in fern
die handgriffe in der küche sitzen fast
blind solche alltäglichkeiten werden sie
wohl vermissten in der neuen heimat
laura mag nicht über die bevorstehende
abreise sprechen
daniel fällt das leichter es fällt ihm
auch leichter auszudrücken was ihm zu
setzt in diesen tagen freunde verlassen
das ist immer schwierig das hält einen
bis zum schluss davon abzugehen die
menschen die man liebt die vier kennen
sich von der arbeit alle an diesem tisch
sind gut ausgebildete informatiker
daniel hat einen bachelor titel wir
können ihn dass das in der schweiz
perspektiven hat
ihr ist es mit der arbeit ja immer
schwieriger was meinst du ich sehe das
auch so
hauptsache es geht ihm gut wenn man
andere möglichkeiten erhält weiter zu
kommen dann muss man das packen
heute ist es ja auch nicht mehr so
schwierig zu integrieren wie es in den
60er jahren war
[Gelächter]
seinen bmw wird er in die schweiz
mitnehmen so viel steht fest
daniel murena ist weder arbeitslos noch
wirtschaftlich am limit im gegenteil er
gehört zum spanischen mittelstand er
fährt ein schickes auto besitzt eine
wohnung und das wichtigste er hatte
einen job
[Musik]
doch die fetten jahre in der hafenstadt
für roller der atlantikküste sind vorbei
die schiffskräne lerne zeichen für
wohlstand sind kaum mehr im einsatz
uns ging es gut und ich hatten die auch
arbeit aber ich glaube die situation in
spanien wird sich weiter massiv
verschlechtern
ich befürchte in zwei bis drei jahren
ist meine ausgangslage um wegzugehen
nicht mehr so gut wie jetzt
man sollte annehmen dass die leute die
gut ausgebildet sind und viel erfahrung
mitbringen ihr wissen in die unternehmen
einbringen können aber die realität ist
eine andere
die unternehmen sind nur an billigen
arbeitskräften interessiert sie wollen
nicht in wissen investieren und darum
habe ich den eindruck man braucht mich
jeden die firmen wollen einfach nur die
krise überstehen
auch daniel hat in den letzten jahren
immer weniger verdient aber das ist es
nicht ihn enttäuscht besonders wie
spanien in dieser krise kam
so lange wollten zu viele nicht
wahrhaben dass sich längst abzeichnete
schaut euch das an das ist wie ein
monument ein mahnmal wenn diese kleider
nicht hier hängen würden dann würden die
leute vergessen dass dies von den lasten
mitarbeitern sind
wenn man das nicht sieht vergisst man es
aber so muss man sich erinnern
es ist ein symbol für das was passiert
[Musik]
das also ist die heimat von daniel
moritz farrell in galicien
es soll vorkommen dass meiner morgen zur
arbeit gehe und eine geschlossene firma
vorfinden wird uns gesagt
[Musik]
der einst stolze bilanz ist weg
farrell entvölkert sich tausende zogen
schon weg
[Musik]
heute leben nur noch etwa 70.000
menschen hier
[Musik]
in farrell kann fast jeder einen der
schon in der schweiz war so auch bei den
mori das
manuelle ganschow peene arbeitete in der
westschweiz auf dem baum seine frau
mercedes lauras tante war in einem hotel
in lausanne angestellt das paar gehört
zu jenen zehntausenden galizien die
früher in die schweiz emigrierte
[Musik]
und nun wiederholt sich diese
auswanderung
[Musik]
galizien und die schweiz haben eine
gemeinsame geschichte damals in den 60er
jahren war spanien eine diktatur und
galizien eine abgekapselte ärmliche
region die schweiz ein verheißungsvoller
ort
[Musik]
und so nahmen auch viele paare aus
galizien in kauf dass sie ihre kinder
bei den großeltern zurücklassen mussten
so groß war der finanzielle druck und
die schweizer gesetze für den
familiennachzug waren streng vorstand
erklärte wegen der kinder nach galizien
zurück ich verstehe daniel und laura
sehr gut
ich würde es ja auch noch ein wenig
jünger wäre mir ging es damals in der
schweiz sehr gut wenn man die kinder
mitnehmen kann
so wie italien und laura ihre an tieren
dann ist das wunderbar
am nächsten tag besuchen wir die mori
dass ein letztes mal in ihrer wohnung in
fern
nun gilt es ernst
die wohnung wollen sie noch verkaufen
leicht wird das nicht das wissen sie
ein dachgepäckträger war ihnen zu teuer
daniel will mit diesem geld lieber neue
möbel kaufen wenn sie im wallis sind und
so besteht die hausrat für die schweiz
aus dem was in den kofferraum des
sportwagens passt wir nehmen vor allem
kleider für ein tier mitspieler
spielsachen ganz wichtig ein paar
küchenutensilien mehr oder weniger was
im kofferraum platz hat laura wie fühlst
du dich
es ist hart aber es ist so wie es ist
es wird sicher eine gute erfahrung
werden
aber die familie verlassen
ipic
[Musik]
etwas später bietet sie uns dass wir sie
vor laufender kamera nichts mehr fragen
für sie sei das alles ganz schwierig
pass auf daniel drängt darauf uns noch
etwas zu zeigen
zusammen mit einem befreundeten
architekten führte uns zu einer
geisterstadt
[Musik]
das heißt dass das ist eine riesige
überbauung vor zehn jahren haben sie mit
bauen angefangen dann kam die krise
die immobilienkrise die sich abzeichnete
traf voll ein
die hypotheken platzten und das hier ist
übrig geblieben
ruinen das ist eine gute metapher
das lohnt sich gar nicht fertig zu bauen
man sollte es abreißen costa minigolf
heißt der immobilien alptraum
1500 häuser die wenigsten verkauft noch
weniger bewohnt der bauherr der größte
immobilienkonzern spaniens ist
mittlerweile bankrott und sitzt auf über
fünf milliarden euro schulden an carrie
co ist selbstkritisch als kenner der
branche hätte er doch realisieren müssen
was sich da zusammenbraut
ich bin wütend
vor allem auch nicht selbst auch ich
habe die augen verschlossen um mich
nicht richtig informiert nicht
hinterfragt ich habe nicht gelesen was
ich hätte lesen müssen
aber ich muss auch sagen die großen
zeitungen haben nicht die realität wider
gegeben dass diese blase jederzeit hätte
platzen können bis es zu spät war
[Musik]
einen monat später
wir sind im wallis über nacht hat es
geschneit und es ist kalt im brief
[Musik]
hier arbeitet daniel nun bei einer
kleinen informatikfirma aus fast allen
büros tönt es spanisch daniel ist nicht
der einzige spanier hier
pascal senn klusen hat in spanien 5
informatiker rekrutiert und das mit
gutem grund sind sehr wichtig finde ich
auch mal fragen denn für die kunden tat
sicherstellen dass man die laufenden
projekte hat abwicklung zum erfolg das
wachstum wurde für ihren mann sind dir
wirklich wichtig dass die leute der
versuchstiere als knowledge tragen
sprach swiss der firma bringt und damit
das für manche vermieter und entwickler
daniel mori da ist einer dieser
wissensträger er ist stellvertretender
leiter it support endlich könne er sich
einbringen
sein wissen dass in spanien nicht mehr
gefragt gewesen sei aber an die
schweizer arbeitsweise muss er sich noch
gewöhnen
einiges ist hier anders
anderes ist gleich mal sehen wie sich
das einpendelt ob das gute überwiegt
wird die zukunft zeigen
die schweiz bildet zu wenig informatiker
aus für die firma brain tag wurde das zu
einem echten problem
von den 24 angestellten sind 14
schweizer fünf kommen aus spanien einige
aus deutschland
zu den kunden gehören die sbb banken
hochschulen seit kurzem hat die firma
einen mitarbeiter in madrid was kalt
zenklusen konferiert täglich per
computer mit ihm
rosemarie nur der mann in spanien
arbeitete wie die anderen einige monate
im wallis dann beschloss pascals
endlosen ihn nach madrid zurück zu
schicken und dort mit ihm eine filiale
zu eröffnen
pascals endlosen zahlt all seinen
spanischen angestellten dieselben löhne
wie den schweizern
sie hätten schließlich ähnlich
abschlüsse ähnliche sportliche ziele
öffentlich oder privat junior sie tat
und da muss man sich genau weil der
universität dass man die personen tüte
rekrutieren
maxi toll innerhalb von dem start der
show das wissen bach herunter küste
themengebiete zu wenig oder nimmt immer
gleich in die tat um und richtet und wie
das zum delhi an der schweizer
fachhochschul- oder einer schweizer
universität gemacht wird
auch daniel mori da wird sich in der
praxis bewähren müssen
sein chef erwartet zum beispiel von ihm
dass er deutschland
und die familie muss sich erst einmal
auf den winter im wallis einstellen
von der atlantik küste sind sie zwar
raue winde gewöhnt aber etwas mehr stoff
am körper muss schon sein
[Musik]
so sieht es gut aus
kaufen wir
daniel hat für seine familie in brieg
eine große wohnung gefunden
das ist unser neues zuhause
mal sehen ob es euch gefällt ich zeige
es euch hier ist der balkon ist recht
groß
das ist etwas kalt draußen weil es
schneit gefällt ihr die aussicht
schön ist und ruhig daniel ist ganz
begeistert schaut alles ist neu gebaut
das hier ist ganz spannend
wie heißt das habt ihr den schon mal
gebraucht da einmal reise haben wir
gekauft
[Musik]
obwohl sie schon vier wochen hier sind
die wohnung wirkt noch ungewohnt familie
moreda braucht ganz offensichtlich etwas
länger zeit um wallis anzukommen
laura hat heimweh sie plant bereits
wieder nach farrell zu reisen um ihre
eltern zu besuchen
habt keine angst ich bin bei euch daniel
hat es einfacher als seine frau er hat
anschluss sein chef kümmert sich sehr um
seine mitarbeiter er will dass sich die
spanier wohl fühlen in der neuen heimat
und darum organisiert pascal zenklusen
öfters ausflüge mit ihnen mit der
seilbahn geht auf die bälle und von dort
soll es mit dem schlitten wieder runter
gehen da vorne ist schon eine gekippt
das ist gefährlich
es ist stockdunkel und es regnet aber
die spanier halten mit den walliser
kollegen wird
[Musik]
und letzte kurve ich weiß nicht die
hätte dich umbringen können
und dann sitzen sie zusammen
die spanier die deutschen und die wahl
ist und sie passen gut zusammen
[Musik]
letzte frage an daniel was ist wenn es
nicht funktioniert da mache ich mir
keine gedanken wirklich nicht daran
denke ich nicht
dann ist es also galizien schweiz
einfach für den moment sicher
[Musik]
den gedanken
die
[Musik]